[Music]
at the stroke of the midnight hour is
marvel aeration with those words on the
eve of august 15 1947. i love me some
historical fiction so i was very excited
when i saw this intro shift to sepia and
this film reel got queued up especially
since this is a place in time i know
little to nothing about but then i
realized it wasn't one of the characters
watching this archival footage it was
just me marvel's tricked me into this
expositional history class and all my
instincts from childhood tell me i
should resist it by kicking and sinning
scene opens on the feet of someone
running fetish i i mean cliche
bringing a knife to a gunfight i mean it
ends up working out but doesn't make it
any less of a sin my hands are tied
the sin as always is the british
poking someone with your stick without
explicit consent touch me and i'll break
your leg
what you mean this one assange laughs
this off because one of his legs isn't
very good but regardless it'd still be
incredibly painful to have it broken and
it's not like she specified which leg
she'd even be breaking also villagers
are now speaking in english to each
other even though in the previous scene
they were not no human alive can resist
the smell of a fresh fried paratha
paratha boasting barathasting
boseparathing
also this works do you know when i saw
you out there
it reminded me of my favorite poem i
can't hear whether or not he says poem
or poet but the subtitles of my version
say favorite poem while hassan goes on
to describe two different quotes by the
same poet so whether it's the fault of
the person who said the words or the
person who transcribed them here's a sin
aisha she who lives
a beautiful man tv shows and movies
always act like knowing the meaning of
someone's name is second nature well i
don't know the exact percentage of
people that memorize what every name
means in their language i feel safe in
saying it's less than one percent
furthermore tv shows and movies treat
this particular skill as if it's
romantic or cute where it's actually
creepy as hell aisha should be running
now because it's 50 50 or whether or not
hassan is a serial killer
aisha is not singing me a lullaby in
this scene
sweeps across the country the prime
minister urges india's citizens to
remain calm by saying
that wasn't clever editing by us these
lines just hilariously line up on their
own and making jokes out of your
dialogue is supposed to be my job of
course i do
but i hit the bangle for safekeeping you
have until sundown tomorrow this is one
of the most uncomfortable conversations
i've ever seen and each character is
telegraphing super hard how their
intentions do not match what they're
actually saying it's so obvious that i
have no idea why either of them is
attempting a ruse and it's surprising
that this doesn't immediately break down
into a brawl in which all of hassan's
roses get trampled
oh look at that another object imbued
with mystical powers glows purple in a
marvel property probably all connected
or some right she knew i was running
from something
but she never never pushed because i
didn't care and you're hot or uh i mean
the didn't care thing that's what i
meant
i'll find it if it's the last thing i do
sure we all knew aisha was going to die
or at least disappear because kamala's
father prophesied it at the dinner table
in episode 2. but still finding the
bengal probably could have been the
first or maybe even second thing you did
if you hadn't killed the person who
knows where it is and where it's going
you have
everything that should be except for a
more precise explanation of how i got
here and what i'm supposed to be doing
now that i'm here but sure i'll take
this picture and hope for the best
you're supposed to save nani like the
story
she's okay
because you are here sho tries to
downplay it but it pretty much just
pulled it back to the future by creating
a situation where kamala has to help her
grandmother get to the train in order to
ensure her own existence she just died
from a pretty severe stab wound and yet
there's not an ounce of blood to be seen
just saying this is one of many ways
modern media is giving our kids
unrealistic expectations
for as simple a premise as it is a lost
child continues to be one of the
scariest things one can see on screen
i'm a bit resentful of the writers for
using this against my emotions
how exactly is this more effective than
carrying her grandmother back to hassan
the crowd of people is still in the way
it'd be one thing if she formed these
things up and over the crowd but she's
putting them at max one to two feet off
of the ground alright i get that
everybody here probably has bigger
concerns at the moment but kamala using
her powers seemed to be a pretty big
deal to everyone in her time period now
i'm not expecting everyone to start
posting about it on social media but i'm
sure at least a few of these people
would be like what the [ __ ] is this
i see the writers have decided the
biggest threat to kamal's powers will be
slight bumps and distractions it was me
kamala doesn't acknowledge how this time
loop nonsense of traveling from the
future to create your own past can
really with your concept of free will
this line was not preceded by if my
train goes off the track she's not
picking up the phone
i mean she's still not home i'm doubling
the previous sin because now my
neighbor's just showing off you know
magnum got lost once i had him microchip
okay ami magnum is a dog kamala's
grandmother has been extremely generous
and wise up to this point so i'm not
buying for a second she would think this
magnum story was in any way relatable to
what kamala's mom is going through well
if kamala's phone is on your family plan
you can just log into your account and
use the find my phone feature to see
where she is explaining things to old
people in a condescending manner because
technology is just so easy for you
having grown up with it all your lives
with cell phones and handheld computers
listen your parents managed to learn and
unlearn some of the most unintuitive
computer systems the world has ever
known and they did it well before they
decided to tell everyone you were not a
mistake so cut them some slack and
explain things with a little bit of
patience you mac wielding [ __ ] um
kids
the sin is kids this episode raiders of
the lost ark so fast i think i got
whiplash and don't forget that in the
latin alphabet jehovah begins with an i
in case that information becomes useful
to you when you're on your last crusade
this is as good as any time to ask does
comron have a father i feel like he may
be a curiously absent character i hope
najma reveals that oh never mind
this works
i don't know but i like to think
[Music]
two people fell in love skip frank
this is either an attempt to convey the
bruno views comrade as a threat or the
writers using the old jump scare equals
bad person or bad motives trick i'm
sending it as the latter because i'm a
betting man and that seems like the
direction this is all going
department of damage control my ass
god it's so crowded how could there be
so many people
are you too good for your home
so
do you have a name
you that's my name
i know that you're pretty attached to
that rotting tree branch
but i thought it might be nice to have a
walking stick that
actually helped you walk i really value
your criticism but maybe you were being
a little hasty here i shouldn't have
never pushed because i didn't care
stay alive no matter what occurs i will
find you
i'll find it if it's the last thing i do
i feel like i've been steady
it was me
[Music]
it all started when a time travel
experiment i was conducting went a
little kaka